[Music]
hey you guys what's up yeah
um is this microphone working i guess it
should be it says blue yeti on it every
now and then it turns itself off but i'm
not really sure so uh last night we saw
uh shut in well it was thursday night
thursday what i was going to say before
we started
is that if you suddenly hear classic
rock blaring through it's not me uh our
neighbors are having a super bowl party
that's ridiculous and earlier like five
or ten minutes before we started
it was so loud the classic rock
that i thought it was it sounds like
it's in the room with me like in the
office with me yeah and those dudes are
country as [ __ ] i don't know what these
country straight dudes are listening to
watching football for i mean the
footballs come out said it was gay so
you know maybe they just decide they
must if they're flipping gay on me over
there i don't know
i don't know what you're talking about
nfl they said they were gay but okay
whatever yeah but uh
whatever yeah
who
cares this is the dumbest conversation
ever but no they were like i don't know
why this is watching
millions of people watch it they didn't
watch anything else it was gay still
watch it they would yeah i'm just saying
i did i forgot because then dudes
running around playing with balls and
[ __ ] flicking them tight-ass pants you
know what i mean they don't look
straight to me it just does yeah they've
been comedians have been saying that
since the 80s yes
um no but what i wanted to say is if
music starts blaring it's not me it's
them it's like super super loud i know
zach but
uh probably not i don't think he usually
comes up
but yeah he's gonna have him tell me how
gay he thought football was
because i know he's gonna say oh yeah
that's just sexy
anyway
we
we saw this movie uh i thought it was
last night but you know how my how am i
it's third it was thursday thursday jen
you gotta correct me on that one
so i shut in
all right my friend and
uh he's a listener on the show i went to
school with him
uh brian he uh did the sound on this on
this movie he also did the uh sound on
vfw which is another movie i like he did
a bunch of other ones movies that i like
i can't recall them off the top of my
head right now just feel like i just
woke up i don't know what it is anyway
yeah what's your deal i don't know
he also did uh terror on the prairie
which is coming out in a couple months
he says that one's even better than this
one they they had a trailer for this uh
this world premiered on youtube
thursday night saw it for free they had
78 or 80 000 people watching it for free
on a live stream
took a while for the live stream was
[ __ ] up for a bit in the very
beginning they finally got that
technical difficult i was counting down
and then it worked i've never so
sometimes
sometimes you get to see the premiere
for free
so uh anyway this movie is made by uh
daily wire you know it's got that ben
shapiro dude so
kind of like the gimmick is is that it's
not hollywood it's like an independent
films and it's
and it just doesn't i guess you say kind
of has i guess kind of like traditional
i don't want to say right wing but just
kind of just does it though we'll see
that's the thing about it i didn't see
that
i didn't either and well here's the dumb
thing about this um and i will say this
was actually a decent movie it's a
psychological thriller we'll get into it
in a little bit but when i looked more
into the thing because when we were
watching it yeah and they had that
douchey um introduction yeah it
shouldn't have been there where i was
just kind of like can we just watch the
movie without you banging on about
whatever the [ __ ] you're banging on
about and um it was just really dumb and
they were talking about this movie's so
brave and hollywood would never make
anything like this and i'm like you know
what's stupid about that is that this
the screenplay let me talk the
screenplay for this written by melanie
toast
uh was actually on the hollywood
blacklist which if you don't know what
that is
that's every year um hollywood producers
directors insiders everybody like that
they vote on what they think are the
best or their most liked uh screenplays
for that year that have been unproduced
so this one shut in uh was on the one
for 2019.
and matter of fact uh back in 2019
hollywood or at least new line cinema
actually was going to make this and it
was in uh development jason bateman was
actually going to direct it but then
like it fell through so they didn't end
up making it
so then later they uh made it and the
guy that directed this was dj caruso
and he also directed the salton c uh
which was actually a pretty good flick
with val kilmer
he did um disturbia uh which was also a
pretty good flick also he did the
disappointments room with kate
beckinsale which was not really that
good a flick it was okay but it was like
a horror it was a horror movie it was
all right but it wasn't really that
fantastic i wrote about it on my blog
like a while back
but um see ya so yeah
so this movie i guess the idea for it
has been floating around for a while the
script has been on the hot was on the
hollywood black list in 2009 so they
finally did make it and then daily wire
ended up picking it up and this is kind
of like their first one so i will say
that even though we're reviewing this
movie and it premiered on thursday night
on youtube you could watch it for free
but
uh if you want to watch it now you gotta
pay you have to go to the daily wire
which is like you know conservative
right wing site and you have to go to
their 12 or their 20 tier to watch it
you cannot watch it they're not
streaming it right there on youtube nope
i thought you could get okay you can't
get it there huh nope that's a good
daily wire that kind of sucks and they
want 12 for it yeah you have to go to at
least the 12 here you can't because they
have a five dollar tier two but they're
not going to let you watch it on there
okay uh so yeah you have to pay 12 a
month or 20 a month to watch this movie
which um
it's good but i don't think it's not
it's not worth it
i'm just saying it's not worth it but
it's but it's not a bad flick though
it's i i actually quite enjoyed it yeah
i
the movie itself was just a decent movie
i mean i would i would call it a
competitive movie you can compete with
stuff that hollywood would make oh
that's that's why i thought was so weird
about that whole message at the
beginning was like this doesn't really
seem particularly different to
a regular psychological thriller there
wasn't anything in it that i would have
considered
well you know what all that different
there was there was some religious
symbolism there yeah but it wasn't
heavy-handed no and i like my atheist
ass wasn't bothered i wasn't bothered
religion is a thing as a thing people
have religions you know uh religious
symbolism is sometimes used in a lot of
stuff just didn't really pop out as
particularly right-wing or christianity
no not at all
like it had some religious symbolism but
nothing that's not in other secular
movies it didn't bother me
and um
quality was good quality of the
production yeah the acting was quite i
mean these are actually like you know
actors that i've seen in other things
the thing is is that that that that when
it was opening it up and the kind of
like the way they're trying to sell
these movies almost makes you think it's
like a pure flick like a christian
that's the important because i was
watching that because i didn't realize
like who was putting this out at first
and then i saw that introduction i'm
like oh god did i get pulled into some
like right-wing [ __ ] i don't know and
then
and then but then i was watching it and
i was like oh this is a normal movie
yeah and then like it's almost kind of
like
a lot better than say like a hallmark
flick but yeah it definitely was the way
they were trying to talk about it it was
kind of like oh we're going to do it
and i was like oh [ __ ] is this going to
be like one of the hallmark movies or
what the hell you know i mean
but it wasn't i could have really done
without that douchey intro yeah it
didn't need that i mean it really didn't
need to be in there it kind of spoiled
part aspects of the movie and it also
puts you in a frame of mind to where
you're already kind of prep it's kind of
prejudiced prejudiced to me against the
movie when it i was going like yeah this
is going to suck because i'm sitting
there going oh no
but no it didn't it was just it was a
good movie yeah it was totally it was
totally fine it was totally uh
totally unnecessary they need to let the
viewer make up their mind about the
movie don't tell the viewer what the
movie is let them let the [ __ ] viewer
enjoy it it was just like that beginning
part it was just like so sanctimonious
yeah it was you know it had this whole
undercurrent
we don't want like this hollywood
liberal agenda blah blah blah it was
like that kind of [ __ ] and i was just
kind of like i don't think he said that
he didn't but that's what he talked
about that was the time it was the
sanctimonious i understand that there's
a market that is that is tired of that
but it's just it's not artistic to even
reject address it just put the [ __ ]
movie that's what i was saying i was
like can we please just put the [ __ ]
movie out let him let him enjoy the
movie and [ __ ] what's that good
let them interpret it don't don't
[ __ ] grandstand over that's what i
mean it's like
that dude didn't make the movie anyway
that's what i'm saying shut the [ __ ] up
you didn't make the movie just [ __ ]
show them he didn't direct the movie he
didn't write the movie right it's like
shut the [ __ ] up
just let people watch it
i know it just pissed me off but then
you know what i mean um but i thought
that's i think it's kind of a bad
marketing move it is and now that you
have to go to daily wire and and pay 12
a month to have access to a movie and
there's only like a couple movies up
there right well this is their first one
so they're kind of trying to
i guess what they're trying to do is
they're trying to
basically the reason that they started
getting into making movies is they want
to attract more people to
their site
and they want people to pay so it's
going to be kind of like a netflix
right but it's so it's like behind a
paywall right but up behind it pay well
but that's kind of rough
yeah i think i would rather do it like
streaming all a cart
and something that can compete
price wise with the competition i mean
you probably make more money in the
aggregate and honestly like i said this
movie absolutely does not have to be
behind a paywall on a right-wing site
because it's not it's just a regular
asset
thriller maybe maybe
they're trying to maybe they they're
trying to use psychology and make these
exclusive things like you have to join
the club and like you know i mean you're
i guess but not a good marketing plan
it's not no i don't think i don't think
that's a good idea i think it's going to
go down in flames but it will and then
like i said
it sucks because like i said this is a
pretty decent flick and if you just
released it on normal ass streaming
platforms
then people would probably probably get
like a decent audience you know what i
mean that's what i would do because
honestly like i said um this has like
actual actors that like rainy uh quality
was in it she's like the main character
and she was in uh ocean's eight i think
she was on mad men which is you know a
fantastic uh series so she plays this
what was her name in the movie jessica i
think i think her name was jessica and
she plays she's an ex-drug addict i
think in the thing it said heroin but
i'm pretty sure it was meth yeah but she
was like a a recovered drug addict
and she's a single mom she has a little
girl and whose name is lainey and then
she has like a little baby boy named
mason
and she gets left her grandmother's
house like after her grandmother dies
and it's kind of like a big old
ramshackle kind of farm type situation
she gets left that and she's kind of
having a hard time she's struggling you
know because she's a single mom and her
ex-boyfriend who is still a junkie uh
she just kicked him out so she's like
well i can't afford to pay the taxes on
this house that i inherited so i'm gonna
move to texas
but then it happens that her scumbag
ex-boyfriend who's actually played by
the guy that was in the vast of night
you remember that movie on amazon prime
that was a great movie too by the way we
reviewed that a while back but uh yeah
he plays this gunbag ex-boyfriend and he
ends up coming back
and they get into a fight oh with his uh
scumbag friend played by vincent gallo
who is
uh implied that he's a pedo yeah and a
drug addict so you know fun times and so
they come back and they get into an
argument and uh it so happens that
jessica gets
nailed into the pantry and she can't get
out
so and then like her kids are still like
on the outside of the thing and that's
pretty much
the set i mean other stuff happens but
that's pretty much the steps largely it
takes place in this one house with her
trapped in this pantry
trying to get out yeah
but that's pretty much uh the setup of
it
and uh honestly like i said it's pretty
good it's pretty tense
you know what my favorite thing in it
what and i'm and this is something
coming for me because i'm not a big fan
of kids in movies that little girl in
the movie was darling yeah
her little voice was like so so funny
because like you heard because uh the
reason we found out about this movie
because like the guy that did the sound
on it
like uh told us about it
and so he was the one that did all the
sound right yeah and honestly the sound
design in this was really good
especially because the girl running yeah
like jessica being trapped in the pantry
and then her having this little girl
who's what like three or four or
something like that she's pretty small
and trying to get she's not any much of
a help yeah i mean she's just little she
can't really help all that much and so
like her having to ask this little girl
to go get things and so you can't really
see her you just hear a little feet
going
and then she comes back mason pooped
you know like that kind of stuff yeah
and i was just like that little girl is
so [ __ ] cute yeah she was so [ __ ]
friends brian i guess he he said he
liked the movie but he said there was
some stuff that got cut out that he
thought he thought would have made the
movie a lot better had to do certain
death scenes and stuff
guys falling from windows but i don't i
hadn't seen the footage that he was
talking about
well now that's why i don't want to well
does it matter if we spoil it because
i'm imagining most people won't be able
to see it
yeah i don't really understand unless
unless daley wire gives up and is like
[ __ ] it we'll just put it on a streaming
service like a normal person yeah why is
this just not on amazon
that's what i mean that's so dumb it's
like i don't understand like why they
try to develop their own platform but
maybe but this is the thing you do that
later once you have a bunch of movies
yeah don't just do it with one movie
because it's like who the hell is going
to do it just for that one movie
as good as that movie is and like i said
this is a pretty good movie yeah but and
one i really want to see is the next one
is coming out that um tear around the
prairie is supposed to be really yeah
it's like a western western and even
when we saw the premiere of this they
showed the um yeah the trailer for that
that does look pretty decent and they
had a trailer for a kids superhero movie
that uh friendly didn't look too good
no that really didn't look too good
though they had the edit in that trailer
what the hell was that what was it
called i don't know um super kids i
don't know no
[ __ ] no i can't remember the name of it
yeah cause i was like ah that doesn't
look like it doesn't look great
yeah it was called the some things but i
can't remember like what it was exactly
it did not it did not look exciting
the edit didn't look exciting i don't
i mean i don't i haven't seen the movie
i was just talking about the the trailer
to that movie yeah i think i'd go fix
that trailer or maybe that's the nature
of that movie i don't know see it's hard
to tell because a lot of times we've
kind of talked about this before
making a trailer is also an art in
itself
uh because sometimes i've seen some
shitty ass trailers and then i actually
did go to see the movie and i'm like oh
man that movie was like so much better
than the trailer implied
and then sometimes i've seen like a
kick-ass trailer and then you go see the
movie and you're like hey
the movie wasn't that good based on the
trailer it looks like it's maybe
something kind of like turbo kid
yeah
meets like a second or third tier the
incredibles except not animated kick ass
meets kick at yeah i got a little bit of
a kick ass vibe
but it was just something that looks
substandard about it and it's that's the
way that that trailer is yeah i know
exactly what you're talking about that
did kind of look like yeah
very bland looking but yeah i mean the
trailer to [ __ ] tear on the prairie
looked great though that actually did
look pretty good yeah yeah but um i mean
i'm not a huge fan of westerns but i
mean i'll watch any genre if it's good
so i'm not really bothered this platform
thing man i just
there's already too many platforms
yeah it's like everybody can't have
their own platform right i mean you can
but i just don't know how well that's
gonna work out for you i would sell this
[ __ ] blu-ray a la carte just buy the
blu-rays
i mean yeah it's like why don't they do
stuff like like normal indie filmmakers
or something like that or you can
license it
to you know amazon prime or whatever or
maybe that's what they're gonna or to be
or something i don't know how i don't
actually know how um something that's
free to watch like to be or pluto
i'm not really sure how it works like
licensing wise because it does seem like
2b for example has a fuckton of really
cheap like indie movies so i don't know
if you get like some kind of like
money every time somebody watches it
because 2b is free to the viewer but
there's ads on it so i'm assuming
there's like ad revenue coming in
somewhere i just don't know how the how
the fee schedule works out for that
but it does seem like you can get your
[ __ ] on 2b
yeah fairly easily and you know it just
it's the the political slant
to the to the to the project that wasn't
there when i looked at it i didn't which
i think that's a good thing the
hyperions that was the name of it
that's right i knew it was the some
things i just couldn't remember what it
was the movie i think just stood on its
own i thought so too didn't need
anything uh but the platform the ben
shapiro thing look i don't like i don't
like democrats i don't like republicans
i think they're both full of [ __ ] all
right i think it's i think they're
just two
bands of [ __ ] liars and thieves
and ben shapiro i mean some of the [ __ ]
i've heard him say is [ __ ] fine you
know i don't have anything against him
just he talks too fast as soon as you
start talking fast like that you're just
you're deceptive yeah that's don't like
but then
that
okay man look let's set the [ __ ] down i
don't want to hear it it's just i don't
know
and he's behind the project i don't know
man just i'm skeptical i'm scared see
but that's what i mean and that's what
that's what weirded me out about this
whole thing because like i said i didn't
really i didn't know that there was all
of this political crap going on behind
this it didn't mean i just have it it
was right and it's just like and i
thought it's just like a [ __ ] movie
because we just knew a guy that worked
on it
so i was like oh okay free movie we're
premiering and we know somebody that did
the sound on it and that's really neat
and then this you know the intro starts
and i'm like oh god now what and you
know what i mean it's like i don't want
to be tricked into like watching some
right wing [ __ ] and then you know what i
mean it's like i was in a bad mood i got
no problem right-wing [ __ ] long as it's
good man
right
conan
but see stuff like that doesn't strike
me as that and
right but this movie it's kind of the
same thing it's i think they overplayed
you know in this douchey introduction
that we talked about they overplayed how
different this movie was they overplayed
like what values this movie is promoting
i'm like this is just like a regular
thriller there wasn't anything okay look
what was in there that would have that
was particularly
it i didn't really i didn't catch i
don't think i think right now the past
couple years you haven't really seen
movies so much like this i mean you
would but you wouldn't hear much about
it they wouldn't be promoted it'd be
something that they would just show
randomly at [ __ ] amc
i mean thrillers they're kind of like
a lot of people make them well and a lot
of people make them because they're
inexpensive right and they tend to have
higher returns for me
when it came to messaging and content
this was kind of like a movie of the
[ __ ] of the late 90s early 2000s
that it could have fit right in there
you still saw
sometimes religious messaging you saw
drug
stuff and
it just wasn't that different
that's what i mean it to me it didn't
strike me as different at all because
like i said i've seen lots of movies
like horror movies all kind of movies
that have quote unquote religious
symbolism and like every [ __ ] every
exorcist movie ever made another thing
that that dude brought up he said that
the the version of this movie they were
they were gonna do had a lot less
dialogue there's more action to to play
more for the chinese market
which i can see that there is some [ __ ]
that they change for the chinese market
and foreign markets
hollywood is they make them they'll
build a movie by committee
and sometimes the art suffers i mean
well yeah i don't think anybody's
looking what they did to star wars
nobody's arguing with that and like i
said that's been going on since the
[ __ ] start of hollywood they've
honestly there's so much money that
they're putting on the line they want a
return on that investment so and sadly a
lot of times the best way to do that is
to make something that will please as
many people as possible
and offend as few people as possible so
a lot of times she gets kind of like
bland ass movies you know what i mean
that's just kind of what happens and
then what's funny is what with that one
that they made for china [ __ ] was
[ __ ] bad ass meg remember the mega
dot the mag yeah the mag that was made
for chyna china
that was actually a pretty fun that was
a pretty fun movie yeah
just dumb shark movie
jason statham [ __ ] hot chinese chick
they're getting eaten by sharks the
shark is [ __ ] huge you know that's
all it's all about
i mean sense though when you're there
i'm pretty much on board with any kind
of shark move
any kind of shark movie there's 40
bajillion of them well because i think
there's a reason for that is because
sharks are [ __ ] scary they're real
and they're scary they could really eat
you in real life so was the movie good
yeah it was good it was good it was
quite i quite liked it yeah would it be
good
no no
no would it be 5.99 good on amazon yeah
yeah like if they were charging like
five bucks to rent it yeah yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't feel bad yeah it was
decent the acting was really good like i
said that there was actually like a
really lot of tension
she can't get out of this [ __ ] pantry
her little kids are you know if you know
that she's a tiny little girl and a baby
yeah and she's trying to like tell the
little girl hey you got to change the
little kid's diaper and hey give him
some apple butter because they've
already packed up all the food in the
car she can't get out and all this other
kind of stuff so having this little girl
like trying to take care of this baby
and then you have like this [ __ ]
junkie and his pedo friend coming over
like in the pedos like after the little
girl and all this other kind of [ __ ] and
you can just hear all the [ __ ] going on
like upstairs and you know jessica and
the banter pantry is like freaking out
so there was like a lot of really good
tension there was like some good uh good
uh violence in there like what i'm not
gonna well like i said it doesn't matter
if i spoil it because
i think eventually it'll probably come
out it'd probably get this on blu-ray
yeah they'll probably have it on dvd and
blu-ray would i pay 10 bucks for dvd or
blu-ray yeah maybe
maybe yeah it's kind of lower on my list
because it's got a lot of stuff i gotta
get zardoz first
but um
i think terror on the prairie is gonna
be a lot better and [ __ ] brian says
that
that from what he saw working on the
[ __ ] terror on the prairie that that
thing's gonna be bad ass talking about
like clint eastwood level
[ __ ] you know
clint eastwood level at least
so we're talking you know
pale ryder and [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ]
i mean we'll see i hope so we'll see but
i can't believe you know what though i
said when i said earlier like i'm going
back a long way now but when i said this
movie here that we're talking about shut
in was directed by dj caruso
um and i said that he had also done the
salt and sea
and i was like you seriously never saw
the salton sea that movie i thought we
watched it together went to the south of
the scene no i know you did but i
thought we watched that movie together
like a few years ago like val kilmer was
in it remember what they do and they
shot it there like in that village
around there i can't like remember it's
been years since we've seen that beach
yeah
i could have i could have sworn that we
watched it together maybe i didn't see
it
i mean it's been a while it's probably
been like six or seven years but i'm
pretty sure that we saw it together yeah
because you were like hey i've been
there
right so we ended up watching it i
remember being it being really good
although i don't remember exactly what
happened in it but i remember val kilmer
was in it yeah grandpa says i hate
movies with a political message even if
i agree with the message i'm saying that
same thing man saying
the political message has to be
contained in in the meaning of the story
it's not supposed to be preaching to you
you know what i mean like a good example
is suck in conan
it's [ __ ] filled with [ __ ]
wagnerian lychee and stuff okay but it's
part of the story it's not really
preaching it's just showing you things
showing you certain principles
but here's the good news
that's not in this movie it was just
that little intro of the dude talking
about the movie
he's kind of hype in the movie before
you see it yeah and like i said
what kind of oh man this is going to be
like some [ __ ] pure flick
this isn't going to be that's like the
impression that i got right yeah and i
was just kind of like and the movie is
completely totally not like when you get
to the movies it's it's just a normal
good movie yeah it's just a good movie a
very competitive this would be you know
something hollywood would do
yeah maybe in certain elements of the
story elements about a little bit harder
edged or a little bit stronger in its
opinion but it wasn't annoying
at all it really
without that intro i probably wouldn't
have been able to notice much difference
i wouldn't have either yeah i would like
like i said it would never have occurred
to me that it wasn't hollywood yeah if
that or even just like an indie film
right an indie film of any kind and i
think that's a testament it's it's a
good movie yeah it didn't it oh brian's
here oh it was up brian hi tom and jenny
brian here sound mixer for this glad you
liked i did yeah i quite liked it i
thought it was yeah we liked it i
thought the height i thought the [ __ ]
we were just talking about the intro the
hype man the intro kind of [ __ ]
spoiled the movie because we're like
wait is this going to be like a pure
flick
it's going to be like a hallmark movie
uh like oh man because you know
sometimes if something is like
branded with a strong political message
it [ __ ] spoils it but but the good
news was is that no it's just a normal
movie a [ __ ] good movie with uh yeah
it's just a good intense like
psychological thriller yeah there wasn't
anything that had like some good gore
some good violence in it it just came
across as uh like a real good it didn't
even
it just came across
as a competitive movie it looks like a
hollywood type production
uh the quality's there the acting was
there this
the story was there
um it didn't
yeah it had so it was a little bit
harder edged in certain aspects of the
movie but no it was kind of like a kind
of like something you'd see out of
hollywood
in the 90s and early 2000s when there
was still a certain element of sanity in
hollywood you know which i don't know
hollywood's always been kind of insane
but
um
this could have easily been a hollywood
movie
it can compete with them
cheryl
i didn't know this yeah vincent gallo
yeah i i looked up a little bit about
him because i was like wow i haven't
seen him in a movie for uh a while
i think the last uh big movie he was in
was back in 2013 and i heard he was a
little bit of a crazy person
uh cheryl says i love vincent gallo if
you go to his website you can rent him
for sex for half a million bucks he's
totally serious too damn
that yeah i don't know a [ __ ] ton about
him but yeah that sounds like that
tracks that tracks
no thanks though
he's probably talking gay six i mean
even if i had half a million dollars
yeah
no i i could think of a of a lot more
things that i could yeah that i could
spend half a million dollars that'd be
way down the list sorry vincent but uh
you know you were good in this movie
though playing a creepy aspect
but yeah so
yeah i'm looking forward to see tara on
the prairie yeah i wonder if they're
gonna do it like like they did this one
yeah see we're talk before you got here
brian we were talking about
this thing being behind a paywall
on daily wire
and it's like you got to pay 12 to see
this movie evidently and then what
there's only a couple movies behind that
pay wall i don't really understand how
dollars a month you have to be like a
twelve dollar a month yeah like i don't
know if it's patreon or if they have
their own deal i don't know i'm not
really sure and i'm not going there to
find out yeah that's i think that's a
bad idea it is but i think it's gonna
bite him in the ass and i think
eventually this will probably just end
up going to a regular streaming maybe
just
maybe if daily wire had the ability to
stream all a cart that would make sense
yeah that way you could just let me just
see the movie you could just rent it for
you know 4.99 let me see the movie yeah
for five bucks or something like that
just like everybody it's just like
everywhere else does just like amazon
prime and [ __ ] like that's how i would
do it yeah and then uh sell dvds and
blu-ray copies of it yeah you can do
that too yeah and then each movie has
merchandise you can buy that's just what
i would do i mean that seems like the
best tried and true right they they seem
like they're trying to do their own
thing and i just don't think it's going
to work out
the way they feel
it takes a it takes a while for them to
fine-tune it yeah yeah i mean and if
it's behind a paywall you got to pay
12.99 to get behind it and there's
really only a couple movies there that
strategy is not going to work uh
the general public needs access to the
movie there's got to be a way that they
stream it all a cart to a customer
who just wants to see the movie yeah
that's how i would do it that's what i
mean merchandise replay really because
honestly if you're gonna make it this
big rigmarole yeah for people to see the
movie then they're just not gonna see
the movie they're already having a hard
time getting people to just see normal
movies on amazon that's what i mean
don't make it harder for people which i
think that might have been the reason
why they are trying to sell this so
differently
like this is an exclusive
uh product
which uh yeah maybe it is but you got
you got to watch it out with that
because it didn't work for pure flicks
that and
i'm not sure that's working for hallmark
you know i don't
although i bet you hallmark has a whole
bunch of octogenarians watching their
[ __ ] channel they have a whole
[ __ ] channel and honestly i don't
remember what it was i was reading an
article about this a
few months ago but apparently they
release like a [ __ ] ton of movies every
year yeah like particularly around
christmas because i think they do ones
for like pretty much everything they're
all lit exactly the same way well yeah
they probably shoot a bunch of them at
one time they probably have like a
couple of like warehouses somewhere that
have all these sets this is like near
our new york city set and this is our
you know this and that set and uh they
just go in there and switch out the
actors and
switch out the holidays so this is a
christmas one put some candy canes and
some snow around yeah john gorra says uh
gallo made a movie with sage stallone he
won't release it though yeah hmm
interesting i'll have to look that up
now i'm kind of well says that if
hollywood made it it has to push awoke
agenda yeah recently it does i don't
that's biting him in the ass though
they're not gonna be able to maintain
that
this movie really like i said
was
i would say philosophically was real
close to what you see coming out of
hollywood in the 90s early 2000s
it's not radically different it's just
like
but there were a lot of movies made in
it's just like a survival thriller yeah
is what it is it's just a survival
thriller that's all i had had it been
made by hollywood yeah they had to
probably put a couple of woke
commercials in there
it would have annoyed you but it
probably wouldn't have been it wouldn't
really change the nature of the movie
that much um
there there are i guess you say you
could say that there are some bible
commercials in there
if you want to interpret that way but i
wasn't really interpreting it that way
no i wasn't i wasn't either she just had
she was just uh they were using did some
religious symbolism
which meant that's been in movies for a
long time well the thing about it was
that you know yes she finds a bible in
there which presumably was her
grandmother's yeah and then there's a
bunch of mysteries about the bible
you'll see but it's not like i said it's
not
i i don't know it didn't strike me as
being like really over overtly religious
or anything yeah and it wasn't preacher
just because religious symbolism is just
so ubiquitous in culture so it's almost
kind of like you don't really notice it
anymore it's like i didn't really it
didn't really strike me as anything all
that strange
you know what i mean so
uh let's see i just got the original
knight of living dead 68 on dvd in color
for seven dollars i think i have that
somewhere
the colorized one i have a colorized one
and i have a colorized one that has uh
that's like a riff tracks you also got
the colorized verses of a version of
last man on earth
i don't think i've seen the um never
seen that colorized either i haven't
seen it colorized
what i don't know if i would like that
or not yeah i don't know if i'd like uh
night a living dead color right now the
living dead i'm just so i've seen it
colorized but i'm so used to seeing it
in black and white
and to me it's just like
i don't know just in my head i always
think of it a black and i've seen the
colorized carnival of souls too and even
though they did like a good job on the
colorizing i still prefer to watch it in
black and white to me it's like creepier
to me i don't know
yeah
you know what i'm saying
yeah you know i do agree with the
general sentiment is that there does
need to be hollywood does need
organized competition
if you have a damn monopoly you know
what i mean
but honestly stagnate and honestly i
think nowadays though i don't even think
that's a problem because
the cost of making movies is so
cheap nowadays it's almost not worth
competing against hollywood because it's
uh hollywood is already [ __ ]
fragmenting and breaking apart
you can the some of the indie films are
coming out they're [ __ ] great
yeah and then our access to foreign
films like the koreans are kicking ass
that's what i mean so i kind of feel
like it's not even really a problem
anymore just you know if you're an indie
filmmaker you don't have a [ __ ] ton of
money i mean just
don't worry about the movie making a
billion dollars um you know because
it's not going to but you just have to
like market things to a niche and you
will find a niche and here's another
thing i mean
you can't look at movies like every
[ __ ] movie that comes out every year
it's going to be some kind of classic it
wasn't even like that back in the 70s or
the 80s you were lucky to get four or
five [ __ ] super good movies that year
yeah most of the movies were just like
forgotten the garbage difference or
they're terrible
and uh hollywood has been around for a
long long time going back to what the
20s
30s 20s i think it's about what i mean
earlier well you started you had silent
films in the 1910s i guess but 20s was
kind of
sort of like a lot of those movies
haven't survived over time though
but uh
hollywood was around for about a hundred
years and um in american culture man
there's [ __ ] hundreds and hundreds of
really good movies that you can go back
and watch anytime you want to it's not
like it was back in the day
i mean you can stream it you got a
blu-rays
i mean you can go back and watch the
original jaws you could watch all this
[ __ ] good [ __ ] anytime you want to
so
hollywood has a [ __ ] badass back
cuddle catalog you know like i had never
seen bullet
went back and watch a bullet it was like
yeah that was a pretty good movie
you know
so
what's going on
what comes out this year is kind of
irrelevant you got all that good [ __ ] in
the past you might get one or two good
movies this year well yeah and the thing
about it is that a lot of times movies
need like a few years to stew to like
age to age out you know what i mean i do
like to see new [ __ ] too
but there's so much old [ __ ] that i
still haven't seen or that i just saw
when i was a kid that i want to rewatch
and like i said you know i would never
complain about oh you know stuff shitty
now or anything like that because i was
like i can watch almost any movie that i
can think of
right now yeah and that's amazing when i
was growing up like you could never do
that all right so daily wire movie uh
this is the first one i've seen for them
it was good this i think this is the
first one that they've done
i gave it like a 75 out of 17 78 maybe
okay oh yeah it was worth seeing uh it
com it was uh the quality was high uh
it's as good as hollywood
uh it had its own angle its own story
that it was telling and i'm looking
forward to seeing more from them uh uh
brian says that the movies that are
coming are even better so we'll see
each you know each each movie is done by
different teams so it's going to be hit
and miss it's just the way it is
i question any i question the uh
marketing the way they're doing it
behind paywalls and stuff
but we'll see it'll probably take him a
while to get that right i'd like to see
some [ __ ] horror movies made by these
guys this was close to a horror movie
but i mean a straight up horror movie
probably really yeah this i would call
this like a a thriller but with horror
elements it was like a survival thriller
but it had some horror elements in the
sense that it had like some violence and
gore and stuff i'd like to see some
horror i'd like to see some sci-fi
that might be interesting yeah something
kind of along the lines of damn
uh hunter prey
man
i could really see a company like this
doing something like hunter prey
yeah
yeah so mango says korean movies have
been kicking ass for well over a decade
true yeah but you just seen it back in
the 90s when i was living in korea
though i mean they [ __ ] sucked
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ever now in the 90s when i was there in
korea there were guys my age watching
those movies right along with a minute
[ __ ] sucks
and they grew up to be direct in the
movies that you that are kicking well
that's probably why because they're like
look at these shitty movies we need to
grow up and make some good movies and
they did it was older korean guys making
that [ __ ] [ __ ] they didn't they
didn't know what they were doing grampar
says will y'all venture over to your
neighbors later to enjoy the big game
with a few mundanes no no no
i tend to forget that it's just kind of
like because i don't follow a sports
ball of any type yeah so i the only
reason i knew was because i was reading
an article on a food blog and it was
talking about you know making your super
bowl snacks i'd get drunk i'd get drunk
dressed up in my leather daddy outfit
and go down there and [ __ ] instruct
them on why he'd start grinding up on
everyone's asses you're telling them i
would explain it and lay it all out man
a big old diagram a whole flow chart of
why sports ball is gay
yeah
they wouldn't like that
no probably not i wouldn't like that you
might get beat up it's gay
nothing wrong with gabe actually if it
if it wasn't i want them to face if it
was gay it would be cooler but if it was
openly gay it's closeted it's closeted
yeah that's what makes it not cool
and
they should embrace it yeah they're not
seeing it for what it is i guess that's
gay oracle said uh have you ever seen
burn witch burn i have uh i think
i might have reviewed it i feel like i
cause i watched it not too long ago and
i'm pretty sure i did one of my little
movie reviews on it so go back
you know on my little flickers of fear
thing and it was like several months and
it should be there because i'm pretty
sure
uh mango is um
recommending archive 81 honestly i bet
i've watched it but i don't i think i
still have one or two um left like at
the end
so
uh yeah and i still have to i still
haven't finished midnight mass either
because i'm lame yeah now danny comes
out and says tom cruise in oblivion is
underrated hell yeah i love him i
actually really liked that
i'm not like i said everybody knows i'm
kind of like meh on tom cruise but
oblivion was actually very good
i like tom cruise's movies even the ones
that are not all that great
he's always consistently himself he's
always he's always delivering the goods
he always does what they hire him to do
oblivion i liked it real good i did as
well real good yeah
cheryl says i looked it up i was wrong
it's only 50 000 to rent vincent gallo
not not five hundred thousand what a
bargain you can also purchase his sperm
[Laughter]
again
no thanks
talking about making parallel medias
there needs to be parallel everything's
parallel well like i said there already
is that i'm not really
parallel banking structures parallel
[ __ ] platforms just
yet everything has to become
decentralized you cannot
to high-tech is too powerful
to be left in the hands of just a few
corporations or a few people
it
it was just like we're in a situation
like it was back in the old railroad
monopoly days the railroad was [ __ ]
dangerous back in the day
i mean [ __ ] they could just
there was a dude in carnegie right
carnegie or he was the steel guy who was
that ran the damn railroad i think it
was carnegie right let's see carnegie
rockefeller yeah rockefeller who is that
other person i think i might have been
carnage
uh if he didn't like you
because you said something against him
and he'd make the [ __ ] railroad go
around your town
yeah and if that happened your town
would [ __ ] vanish
so you think the flow of information can
be [ __ ] rooted around you and [ __ ]
you up back in the day man they could
weaponize the railroad against you they
represent the railroad against new york
and brought new york to its knees
until they agreed to uh to something
that the railroad company the railroad
company and the oil companies started to
merge and [ __ ] new york one of those
new york politicians was [ __ ]
fighting against it they blockaded new
york didn't send supplies in there for
like several weeks started to starve out
new york and someone okay okay okay they
relented
this [ __ ]
the oligarchy has been [ __ ] over
america america for [ __ ] over a
hundred years
you know
serious [ __ ] started in the [ __ ] mid
1800s with centralized banking going
back to england and the rockefellers and
[ __ ] they don't teach us the real
history but there are the history
programs that are [ __ ]
the men who built america it's a great
series that's uh i think it was on um
netflix it was on for a while i think
and it'll explain it and have a show on
every one of those demo robber barons
and what they did
they built the infrastructure it did
build the country up rapidly but man my
price was kind of high
not as high i say the soviet union in
stalin but pretty high
these [ __ ] are bad
one asked if i'd seen mark of the devil
i have uh and i actually do want to do a
review on it at some point because i
haven't actually seen it for quite a
long time uh mango is talking about
archive 81 i've got a few eps left we'll
finish tonight i think i have one or two
episodes of archive 81 left midnight
mass i think i watched the first three
or four and then i got distracted and i
hadn't finished it yet but i will get
around to it uh oscar says jenny do all
the vhs movies i know you did uh 84 or
wait was it vhs 84 or vhs 94 yeah we did
that one i will get around to that
because i think i saw the first one and
maybe the second one and i remember them
being good but yeah i'll do maybe i'll
do like all of them in one go
um i'm talking about starting to go fund
me
to buy some offensive gala sperm
it's a nutcase no
[Laughter]
wonder if he's had any takers
uh
probably
not i fetch it
oh my god yeah cheryl said i think i'll
pass i wonder if anyone has though i
mean come on now but uh yeah so anyway
all right so tomorrow is valentine's day
so for the matinee tomorrow we're
actually going to talk about the 2001
slasher valentine
and then the day after because i
couldn't decide which one i wanted to do
the day after valentine's day we're
gonna do another sort of valentine's day
movie which somebody recommended to me
and i had totally forgotten that this
movie took place on valentine's day
picnic at hanging rock
so tuesday we're gonna talk about that
and uh yeah so that'll be good we got
two days of valentine adjacent movies
that should be fun
and uh that's what else do you have to
say anything that's it okay so
uh i guess that'll do it for today
have a good restier weekend
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
afternoon
bye